Phoebe you hang out with older members
of family hmm man I can I can find them
[Applause]
women of the world event that I'd like
gatecrash broken into climbed through a
window into was everyone was being
introduced and Camilla parker-bowles was
approaching me with one of those like
assistance behind her who like tells her
who every coming towards me and she was
she was like giving her ear to the
finger
[Applause]
and then like a TV camera was like
another this is gonna go wrong
I'm I'm writer and I write TV shows and
I'm at sea and I just thought happy to
get you know women into it so that I'm
writing I'm writing a show at the moment
about a female assassin and a female mi5
agent and they're kind of chasing each
other around the world and she was like
oh lovely and I thought you had a lot of
girl-on-girl action your character in
the bag was quite the Barack Obama fan
she was very active fan if you didn't
see it do describe what happened please
you described why no you were you were
feeling you were feeling energetic of a
nighttime mm-hmm but didn't you were
trying not to be energetic of a night
time is that right yes she has a wank -
Obama speech yeah it's the show that
most people come up to me and they say
it's so relatable
[Laughter]
[Music]
you